thank you
white sports cars on samples road going
up to
2020 he's at a high rate of speed take
it off I mean I can't get a tag yet
[Music]
I'm sorry Sanders around in Highway 20
taking a ride up to Beaver Valley
Annihilation will be speeding
relaxed
[Music]
turning this out on the 400 already I'm
just gonna enjoyable
[Music]
white piece on detail
s
I'm losing side of it he's southbound
passing Billy Powell now he's probably
at about 120 so be careful don't miss
him
see
Chuck Lane feel like traffic
spikes and shallows spikes are shallow
looks like he's in the bathroom right
now we just switched to the flowing to
the slow lane right now I'm coming up in
Shiloh though
good fight
[Music]
off him and calling
stand up
[Music]
is it a white BMW
I got him he's going left at McDonald's
[Music]
right
for Nancy Reagan the white BMW
[Music]
right over again
you're right here
90. no traffic
scary
again
[Music]
you cannot have anybody in the area
okay falling down now
right on Union Hill
um guys
left on Tidwell left on Tidwell
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
get your hands out going right now you
gotta pit you gotta pit